- Welcome to A Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler of
the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is
Professor Deborah Tannen.
She is visiting the Berkeley campus
as the 2017 Hitchcock Lecturer.
Since 1979, Tannen has been on the faculty
of Georgetown University's
Department of Linguistics.
And, since 1991, has held the
rank of university professor.
A prolific scholar, Tannen has written
critically praised books for
both scholarly and general audiences.
Her books include the number one,
four year New York Times Bestseller
You Just Don't Understand:
Women and Men in Conversation.
Her most recent book is You're
the Only One I Can Tell:
Inside the Language of
Women's Friendships.
Professor Tannen, welcome to Berkeley.
- So nice to be here.
Be here again.
- Yes, welcome back, I should say.
Where were you born and raised?
- I was born in Brooklyn, New York.
Raised in Brooklyn, New York.
And I have my PhD from Berkeley.
- And, looking back, how did your parents
shape your thinking about the world?
- You know, the very first book
that I wrote in linguistics,
actually was edited,
was about spoken and written language.
Orality and Literacy.
And I dedicated it to my parents.
And I said who taught me about
orality and literacy respectively.
(laughter)
My mother being the orality.
My father being the literacy.
Yeah, my parents were born in Europe.
My father in Poland.
My mother in Russia.
They came to this country,
my father in 1920.
And that's very significant.
That was the last year that
there were no limits on immigration
from that part of the world.
My mother had her father and
some siblings already here.
Tried to come in 1921.
And they had already instituted quotas.
So, they had to hang out in Poland.
They had escaped from
Russia over the border.
They had to hang out in
Poland for about two years
till they were able to come in 1923.
And that was the last year
that anyone could come.
By '24, the quotas were
so high no one could come.
So, they had that background from Europe.
They did not graduate from high
school, either one of them.
But my father did do high
school equivalency at night
while he was working in the factory.
Became a lawyer by attending
law school at night.
Earned a master's degree
in law the same way.
- That background suggests that
you became conscious of conversation
comparing what was being discussed at home
and the way it was discussed
versus the public schools.
Is that fair?
- You know, I trace my interest
in language to my father.
He was very gifted in language,
both speaking languages,
picking them up, and writing.
And he was the one, after people had left
and we would sit around in the evening,
he was the one who would say,
"Did you notice when she said this
and she said it this way?
And what did that mean?"
That was really from him.
My mother was very verbal and storied.
Talked about people, told stories.
Also very interested in
people, their relationships.
I actually have a BA and
MA in English literature.
So, my decision to get
the PhD in linguistics
was not an obvious one.
I was 30.
I had lived in Greece.
And this was also a large part in
my interest in different, what
I call, conversation styles.
Having lived in Greece where
the ways of speaking
were somewhat different.
And so, I think I might
have gone into law,
as my father had done.
Although I didn't really
want to have to wear
what I thought of as lady's shoes
and go on the subway every day.
But, really, I was just bored
and wanted something that would
be intellectually engaging.
And the kind of linguistics
that I do, which...
Fortunately, I attended a
linguistic institute in 1973.
The Linguistic Society
of America has these,
at that time, every summer.
Now every other summer.
And I didn't really know
what linguistics was,
but I was curious.
- This was when you were an undergraduate?
- [Deborah] I am now 30.
- I see.
- Had lived in Greece,
so I had that interest
in cross-cultural communication.
Had a BA and MA in English literature.
I was teaching remedial writing at
the City University of New
York at Lehman College.
And I was just bored and I wanted to
be intellectually engaged again.
I was really thinking more
of being a student again
than I was of a career goal.
And I went to a Linguistic Institute
and I was just so fortunate that,
that summer, the topic
was language in context.
It was 1973.
I think there was a zeitgeist at the time.
Many fields were turning
to everyday interaction.
And that was the case with linguistics.
I took a course with Robin Lakoff
who had just joined the
faculty at Berkeley.
And was just fascinated by her schema
for understanding a face
to face conversation.
And other courses that I took, as well,
really inspired me that way.
All those talks that were
being given that summer
where all the people who
became giants and were,
although I didn't realize they had giants,
in the field of turning to the analysis
of language in everyday interaction.
So, it brought together my father's
love of language and his skill at language
with my mother's interest in people
and her facility with
everyday conversation.
- Is the Linguistics
Institute here at Berkeley?
- [Deborah] It was at the
University of Michigan.
- I see.
But then Robin Lakoff came to Berkeley
or was she already here?
- I think it was the summer between
her leaving Michigan
and coming to Berkeley.
So, I then applied to and came to Berkeley
because she was here.
- Did your background as
an English undergraduate
help you in linguistic studies
or was that just a passing fad?
- You know, it's so
interesting you say that.
There are some of us in linguistics,
again, the kind that I do,
with this English literature background.
So, it was not just my BA,
but also my Master's
in English literature.
And I had actually published
a couple of papers.
One on Yeats and one on Joyce.
And I'm sure that helped my application.
But, yeah, I believe that my love of
and sensitivity to literary
language has been key.
One of my books that is published
that I wrote for scholarly audiences
was published by Cambridge
University Press.
It's called Talking Voices:
Repetition, Dialogue, and Imagery
in Conversational Discourse.
Actually, my title for it was
Conversational and Literary Discourse.
And the theme of that book is that
the figures, the ways of using language
that we think of as being
quintessentially literary,
patterns of repetition, patterns of sound,
using dialogue that is taking the voices
of the people that are speaking,
and details and imagery,
all these things are
thought of as literary,
appreciated in literary language.
But my point there is that they are
the fundamental building blocks
of everyday conversation.
So, you could say that
all my work in linguistics
builds directly on my background
in literary criticism.
I'll just add quickly...
- Yes?
- I actually had written a
book of literary criticism.
It's analysis of the work
of a modern Greek writer.
Her name is Lilika Nakos.
She's not translated.
- What did you do your
dissertation on here at Berkeley?
- My dissertation was called
Conversational Style:
Analyzing Talk among Friends.
But it was a comparison of what
I call conversational style,
ways of speaking, ways of using language,
that were typical of
New York Jewish speakers on the one hand
and California non-Jewish
speakers on the other.
I did not set out to look at
New York versus California
ways of speaking.
My goal, my intention, had been simply to
take a real conversation,
microanalysis of real
everyday conversation,
and describe the conversational styles
of each person in that conversation.
There were six.
And the effects of those
conversational ways of using language
on each other and on the conversation.
Three of the six people
were New York Jews.
I was one, my best
friend, and his brother.
Three of us.
I'm from Brooklyn.
They were from the Bronx.
And then, two of his
friends and his former wife.
She was British and the two friends
had grown up in California.
I discovered, in analyzing
the conversation,
that the New York speakers were able to
express our ways of speaking in a way that
the Californians could not.
Because it was hard for
them to get the floor.
(laughter)
So, I ended up doing a study, really,
of New York conversational style
and the different effect that it had
in the interactions among the three of us,
those who shared that
conversational style,
and how different an effect it had
in the interactions with
the Californians and the British woman.
- I like to ask my guests
how they would advise students who
want to prepare for a career in
the field that the guest is in.
Linguistics, what do you see
is the skills and temperament
involved in mastering that work?
- You need to be compulsive,
but then, most of us
academics are compulsive.
(laughter)
Enormous patience to
look at the nitty gritty.
You have to be kind of picky.
I spent two and a half months
transcribing that two and
a half hour conversation.
I timed the pauses.
Now, a lot of that can
be done computationally.
I transcribed it in a way that showed
whether t-h-e meant the or
whether it represented the.
I used a capital E.
So, that kind of patience
to look in great detail
at the tiny, tiny bits of language,
I think, is something that
you need to be a linguist.
- Listening to you and
reading several of your works.
Listening is very important.
So, a person who's gonna do linguistics
has to be good at that.
- I'm amused by your saying that
because so few people listen.
(laughter)
Including linguists.
But I think, yes, that is very helpful.
Being an observer.
We describe our field, linguistics,
as descriptive, not prescriptive.
And that's one of the things that
distinguishes us from, for example,
people in the field of English literature.
English teachers.
We would never say,
"You're using that wrong."
We would say, "Isn't that interesting?
You used it that way.
Why are you using it that way?
Who else uses it that way?"
So, yeah...
- In reading, again, your works,
you have to be a people person.
That's my conclusion.
But, in the sense that, in a way,
you're being nosy about the way they talk,
so you have to be able to deal with them.
So, your analytical
skills do not upset them.
So, therefore you have
to be a people person
to make them feel good.
Is that...
- I'm fascinated by your saying that.
When I was deciding
which program to go to,
one that I considered was the
University of Pennsylvania
where a leading sociolinguist
was of the time, William Labov.
The kind of work he does is
rather different from mine,
but I did go to meet
with him and talk to him.
And he said, "You have to be comfortable
going out and talking to strangers,
because that's how we record their talk
that we need in order to analyze.
So, if you're not comfortable doing that,
this is not for you."
In the end, I did something different.
But I think it happens to be the case that
many academics are shy.
They're introverts.
They're happier alone in their study
with their computer screen than
they are out talking to people.
And there are many successful
discourse analysts...
The kind of work that I do
would now be called discourse analysis.
Discourse being the language
as it's used in interaction.
There are many who are
quite introverted, quite shy
and are not comfortable
interacting with people.
But that's okay.
They get their recordings
or maybe they look at written language.
Maybe they look at something
they heard on television.
Or maybe they just take time
and are able to get close enough to people
to record their conversation.
- Hey, help us understand
what conversational style is.
- Yes, thank you for asking that.
Conversational style is my main point,
you might say, of everything that I do.
Let me explain it this way.
When I am asked by
people in the real world,
journalists or interviewers on television,
they'll always say, "Wouldn't
this be a better world
if everybody just said what they meant?"
And I often respond,
"We do say what we mean,
but we say it in our own
conversational style."
We have in mind what we want to say,
what we want to accomplish
in this interaction,
but we have to make decisions.
How loudly or softly to speak.
What specific words to choose.
How relatively direct or
indirect we're going to be.
If I want you to close the window,
am I going to say "Close the window"
or am I going to say "It's
kind of cold in here"
and hope you'll conclude that
you should close the window?
A whole range of features that...
Decisions that have to be made
when you take your ideas and emotions
and put them into words.
There are people who, when they're angry,
will get very loud and yell.
There are people who, when
they're angry, will get silent.
All these differences
in conversational style.
Are you gonna show interest in
somebody by asking questions?
Or is it rude to ask questions?
Back off.
They'll tell you what
they want you to know.
And I have applied this in
a huge range of contexts.
It comes up with my starting point,
different regional backgrounds,
different ethnic backgrounds,
different class backgrounds,
individual personality, generation,
sexual orientation, all
these influences on our style
and, of course, gender differences,
which is the topic of the book
You Just Don't Understand,
which is the one that
got the most attention
of my books written for general audiences.
But I would say conversational style
is all the linguistic elements that
make up how you say what you mean.
And they differ by all these influences.
If you talk to someone
whose conversational style
is relatively similar to yours,
chances are your conclusions about
what they mean and what they intend
and their inner abilities
will be relatively accurate.
But, to the extent that the
person you're speaking with
has a different conversational style,
it's quite likely that your conclusions
about their abilities and their intentions
and their conclusions about
yours may not be accurate.
- Also, I want you to explain
the difference between
a communication and a metacommunication.
'Cause I think that's
central to your analysis.
- It is.
These are terms that I borrowed from
the anthropologist Gregory Bateson.
And he pointed out that
anything anyone says
and any gestures they make, as well,
has a message and a metamessage.
So, the message is the
meaning of the words.
The metamessage is how you
should interpret those words.
What you think you're
doing by saying these words
in this way at this time.
And, in so many of the books I've written
where I have examples from real
people in their real lives,
they're arguing about the message,
but it was really the
metamessage that got their goat.
So, when you...
Again, take a simple example.
This was a real
conversation that I observed
walking along campus
with a female colleague.
Male colleague appeared.
It was a brisk fall day.
Kind of chilly.
And we greeted each other
and she said to him,
"Where's your coat?"
And he said, "Thanks, mom."
(laughter)
So, what was the metamessage
of "Where's your coat?"
To her, it was simply
friendly, a greeting.
To him, it was "I'm speaking to you
as a parent would to a child."
And they're both there.
- So, the metamessage is really about
the structure of the relationship,
which is hidden in a way.
- Well, I would say it's everything about
how you mean what you say.
So, it's what you think
of the relationship.
It's also the implications.
So, I gave the example
of "It's cold in here"
as a way to get someone
to close the window.
You could say the metamessage is
"Please, go close the window."
Or you could just say the metamessage is
"I don't want to impose on you.
I don't want to force
you to close the window.
So, I'm being considerate of you."
It's everything about
how you mean what you say
and what it says about the relationship
at the time that you say it.
It's interesting you say it's hidden.
All the books I've written I have examples
of message and metamessage.
And it's so important, because, so often,
people are frustrated
from their conversations.
And they say, "Why did you say that?"
Take mothers and daughters
where daughters frequently felt
that their mothers were critical.
Criticizing, especially, the big three,
hair, clothes, and weight.
And how they raise their
children, if they have children.
And so, the mother would...
Give you my own example.
My mother once said to me,
"Do you like your hair that long?"
Her metamessage, what was it?
I mean, for many people, it
would be "Your hair's too long."
And, as a matter of fact,
later on, she laughed...
At the time that she said it to me,
I laughed and I said,
"You know, so many women tell me that
their mothers criticize their hair."
She said, "I wasn't criticizing."
But then, later, I said,
"Mom, what do you think of my hair?"
And she said, "I think
it's a little too long."
So, I picked up that metamessage
that she's saying something
critical about my hair.
Mothers typically felt their
daughters were so sensitive.
I can't...
"She takes everything as criticism.
I'm concerned.
I'm showing my caring.
I want the world to appreciate her
to see how wonderful she is.
I want things to go as
well as they can for her.
So, if she had a better haircut,
things would go better for her."
So, which is it?
Which metamessage is accurate?
And I think it's so crucial to realize
the metamessage somebody picks up
may not be the one you intend.
So, each one, the mother, the daughter,
feels the metamessage I perceive
or I intend is the real one.
"I'm not criticizing.
I'm showing I care."
"You're criticizing."
And so, it's very crucial point that
I make in so many of these is
that they can both be true.
- I also like to ask my
guests about creativity.
And it strikes me that a
source of your creativity
is your interest in everyday conversation
and your capacity to apply
the theory of linguistics
that was already there
or that you developed.
- Thank you.
That's absolutely right.
And, as I said, I think 1973,
the year that I went to the institute
and then '74 to '79, when I
was in grad school at Berkeley,
there was a turn toward applying
various theories to everyday interaction.
So, we saw it in philosophy.
There was someone named H.P. Grice
who developed the schema
logic of conversation.
He said you could take these
formal schemas of logic
and apply it to everyday conversation.
There was a field called
conversation analysis in sociology.
Sacks, Schegloff, Jefferson.
And it's interesting.
My understanding is that
they took conversations
simply because it was something
form everyday interaction you could
pin down by transcribing it
and showing that it was rule governed
and that it was orderly.
And then there was the
work of Robin Lakoff,
who I mentioned, of John Gumperz,
who was on the anthropology
faculty at the time,
and of Wallace Chafe, who was in
the linguistics department, as well.
All of them turning their interest
to the language of everyday interaction.
And so, yes, that has
always been my passion.
And I think that's my contribution.
And I brought all their theories together.
I don't know how much
detail you want to go into.
How I did that.
And then added, of
course, my own take on it.
Maybe this sensibility of
literary criticism that I brought,
as well as showing how all
these things came together.
- My goal is to make the
audience interested enough in you
to buy all those books.
Which I'm sure you want.
You write about a lot and, in fact...
Were you surprised when your book
You Just Don't Understand:
Women and Men in Conversation
became a four year New
York Times Bestseller?
- Of course.
A four year bestseller?
That doesn't happen.
Everybody would be shocked by that.
But that it became a bestseller at all?
Not only was I surprised,
my publisher was surprised.
There was a period of several months
when they refused to print
enough books to fulfill demand.
They just didn't believe it was happening.
It seemed so unlikely.
I'll tell you something
that's kind of funny.
I had ambitions for the first book
that I wrote for general audiences.
That book was called
That's Not What I Meant.
And it took all the basic ideas
of conversational style and
conversational interaction.
It was a slim book.
Very understandable.
Full of anecdotes and examples
from real interactions.
Just like all my books for
general audiences have been.
That was the one for
which I had ambitions.
It's gonna change the world.
People are gonna see that they think
everything is in terms of
psychological interpretation.
I felt psychologists
had been so much better
at communicating to the general audience
than linguists had been.
That was the one for
which I was ambitious.
The book did okay.
Not that great.
A friend of mine who is also an author,
someone I had met that way,
commented, he said, "You
just want your books
to do well enough that they'll
let you write another one."
I thought, you know, that makes sense.
And I scaled back my ambitions.
And so, when I wrote the book
You Just Don't Understand,
it was with that scaled back anticipation
of how well it might do.
And it was quite shocking.
- Well, one of the things,
when I read it for the first
time in preparation for this,
is, "Oh, my," as you go
over the interactions
between a husband and wife.
You say that communication
between a man and a woman
is cross-cultural communication.
Why do you say that?
- Yes.
- [Harry] It's true.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Of course, it's a metaphor.
And, I have to say, I still...
It just happened last night
when I was giving a talk here at Berkeley.
People will come up to me and say,
"That book changed my life.
That book saved my marriage.
That book gave me a way to
understand what was happening in my life
that I couldn't understand before."
So, that's been a real gift.
But, yeah, I say it's
cross-cultural communication
because I'm using the
model that I developed
based on New York versus
California ways of speaking.
Girls play with girls.
Boys play with boys.
They are treated differently growing up.
They learn ways of using language
among their same sex peers.
They bring those ways of using language
to conversations with men
and women they're close to.
And I use this metaphor, too, sometimes,
that women expect their
husbands, their boyfriends,
their male partners, if
they're heterosexual,
to be a new and improved
version of a best friend.
And they're frustrated when
it doesn't work out that way
and it can come down to
these different conversational styles.
I can give you two key examples
that turned out to be kind of like
what I think of as the
greatest hits from that book.
One is a conversation, takes place when
you're riding in the car.
And the woman says to the
man, "Are you thirsty, dear?
Would you like to stop for a drink?"
And he isn't, so he says no.
And then, later, it turns out
that she had wanted to stop.
And this was told to me by the man
and he said, "Why does
she play games with me?
Why did she want me to be a mind reader?
Why didn't she just tell
me she wanted to stop?"
And my comment was probably
she didn't expect a yes/no answer.
She probably expected something like,
"I don't know.
How do you feel about it?"
And then she could say "I don't know.
And then they could talk about
how they both feel about it
and come to a decision taking
everybody's preferences into account.
So, again, we have
message and metamessage.
When she asked, "Are you thirsty?
Would you like to stop for a drink?"
She's sending a metamessage.
"I want to know what you want.
I'm not gonna impose what I want on you."
And, when he says no,
she hears a metamessage.
"I don't care what you want.
We're gonna do what I want."
This may come up later when he says
"Why didn't you tell me?"
And she says, "We always
do what you want, anyway."
(laughter)
So, it becomes a metamessage about caring.
And that is so much the
case in close relationships.
And I wanna be so clear here.
Most people are inclined to think
one way is good and the other is bad.
So, there are those who think,
"Of course she should say what she means.
I hate this indirectness.
It's passive aggressive."
And there are those who think,
"Of course it would be rude
to say, 'I want to stop.'
That's terrible.
You have to start vague and
find out where everybody is
and make a decision taking
everybody's preferences into account."
Either one works well.
- What was the second example?
- Okay, this is a conversation where
the end of the day, say,
and the woman is telling
a man about a problem and
he tells her how to fix it.
And she's frustrated.
The comment I made at the time
was she didn't want a solution.
She wanted to talk about it.
And he's frustrated because
why would you want to talk about it
if you don't do anything about it.
And I do trace this to ways of speaking
that are quite typical for women and men.
And it's so important for me to say...
I can't say this enough.
We're talking about tendencies,
typical, many, most.
We're not saying all.
Because there are so many
other influences, like culture.
But the tendency is that,
when women might say to
a friend about a problem,
the friend might say, "Oh,
I don't think he said that."
And then "What did you say?"
And then "What do you
think you could have done?"
And "What do you think
he'll do if you do that?"
You ask all these questions
and you do work your way
around to giving advice.
But you need all that information
to know what advice to give.
But, again, message and metamessage.
Being willing to engage in
an extended conversation
about the problem that
someone you care about
is experiencing that in itself
sends a metamessage of caring.
And so, the frustration, I think,
is less she didn't want a solution
than she didn't want it right off the bat.
And the solution cuts
short the conversation.
So, starting the conversation
was probably her motive.
- Everybody has to go
out and read this book.
'Cause it's mind opening.
Especially a husband and wife.
But maybe also others.
In a nutshell, 'cause we had...
I want to go on to political
stuff that you've written.
That you talk about the difference
in wanting solidarity versus
somebody wanting power.
And you have a set of adjectives
and descriptive statements.
Women versus men.
And man, through socialization
and their childhood and other factors,
essentially are interested in hierarchy.
They're interested in power.
They're more focused on
"I'm up and you're down."
Whereas women, as we said
earlier, are into solidarity.
Caring about the other,
bringing everyone along in the circle.
- Yeah, so glad I'm you brought that up.
But I wanna say, right off the bat,
it isn't as absolute as that.
Every interaction is a matter of balancing
a hierarchical dynamic, that
is, who's up, who's down,
and a closeness distance dynamic.
Is this way of talking bring us closer
or pushing us farther apart?
And we're both, women and
men, and all individuals.
Always interested in all these levels.
But it's very common for a woman and a man
to walk away from the same conversation.
One having focused on the question
"Does this put me in a one
up, one down position?"
And the other having
focused on the question
"Does it bring us closer
or push us farther apart?"
And, again, it's important to say
tends to, common, often, not
everybody, and not always.
But the example I gave earlier
is a perfect example of that.
The question "Where's your coat?"
If you focus on the closeness-distance,
I'm being friendly, showing
you that I care about you.
The hierarchical
dimension is "Thanks mom."
You're the mother talking to the child.
Just a very few quick examples.
Women, a man...
These are all real
examples that I encountered
and that I give in the book.
Man tells his wife, "Hey, I got a call
from my high school friend.
He's gonna be in town Friday.
I'm gonna have dinner with him."
And she feels hurt.
"You shouldn't present
this as a fete complete,
we should discuss it.
Maybe I had plans for Friday night.
You know, we're in this together."
And he said, "I can't tell my friend
I need to ask my wife for permission."
So, is checking with her
asking for permission?
That's the who's up, who's down.
Is it showing caring?
"We're involved.
Our lives are wrapped up together.
There's somebody who's
going to be impacted
if I make a decision to
have dinner with you."
So, it's just which one you focus on.
And I have many other examples like that.
- Maybe I should develop
an app as a wedding planner
and make your book available
as a part of the gift package.
Now, I want to actually
move to a different area,
which is about civic
discourse, politics today,
and how some of your analysis might apply.
And let me ask, in researching
for this interview,
I found a book that you had written
on a critique of America's
argument culture.
And the book was published in 1999.
Very prescient.
Tell us about your idea there.
- Yes, the book is called
The Argument Culture: Stopping
America's War of Words.
The hardback subtitle was
moving from debate to dialogue.
The idea was that we are approaching...
I say we, our American culture,
but, maybe more broadly, world culture,
certainly European culture.
We are approaching more and more things
in an adversarial spirit.
It's an overapplication
of the assumption that
the best way to come to truth is debate.
That means find two people
as opposed as possible,
the most extreme ends of
the continuum as possible,
and let them fight about it.
And this brings us to all the aspects
of the press that I write about.
One is the tendency to approach everything
as two sides in a debate.
Whereas most things don't have two sides.
They have many sides.
The other is the valuation of attack.
And we have seen this more and more.
That journalists see as their
responsibility to attack,
to find what's wrong, to
write negative stories.
If you were to write a positive
story, that's a puff piece.
And they're embarrassed to do that.
It wouldn't be respected
by their colleagues.
So, that's the press.
And I also wrote about politics.
There was so much evidence
at the time that I wrote it
and there's more now that,
whereas in the past, the two
parties could work together,
at least to some degree.
That it had become so polarized that
there was no meeting ground at all.
And, of course, it's the Republicans,
we might as well just say it
out there, because it's true,
that the Republicans have decided that
the path forward is to oppose
anything the Democrats want.
And it may be what they wanted before,
but now the Democrats want it,
so they're just gonna stop it.
And so, the press, politics, and academia.
And that's kind of where
I started with all this.
That many people feel the
way to start an article
in an academic article...
Say what's been done before
and what's wrong with it.
So that you can be right
and they can be wrong.
But that isn't the way we're
gonna come to understanding.
Yeah, sometimes it's great to say,
"Read this article.
Tell me what's wrong with it."
But there are other
things you can do, too.
"Read this article and see
what you can use in it."
Things you don't agree with,
where did it come from?
Maybe it comes out of a
different intellectual tradition.
How was it related to things we've read
in the intellectual tradition we prefer?
- So, synthesis and integration
and respectful reading of
those you oppose, in a way.
- Yes, you're right to
use the word respectful,
but I think some people would see
the oppositional discourse as respectful.
And, in fact, they might think that,
if you don't attack and
ask critical questions,
that's a lack of respect.
So, what I'm trying to
call attention to there
is something a little bit different.
That we should realize this
is not the only way to truth
and that it has many
negative consequences.
And what I had in mind
there, among others,
was ways that it obscures truth.
And, goodness, we are seeing this
in the current environment.
If journalists are gonna
put everything into...
One example of this is the idea that
everything is opposing camps.
You end up with this false equivalence.
I have to have two sides to every debate.
So, if I'm gonna write
about climate change,
I need to say something
about the people who oppose,
who say there's no such
thing as climate change.
But the fact is there's only
a few people who say that
and they're all the same ones.
And they were funded by
the fossil fuel industry.
And yet, there they were, over and over,
again, back in the late '90s,
being cited as if this were
really two sides of a debate.
I use the example of the Holocaust.
The United States, in the United States,
Holocaust deniers have had
more success than any other country.
And I was able to show
that the reason was that
here they could masquerade as
the other side in a debate.
And there's no better example that
there are some situations
where there is no other side.
There's truth.
- You wrote this in the '90s, 1990s.
It's gotten much worse.
And you talk about the factors that
influence the conversational style.
And we're seeing stark inequality.
City-rural divide.
Cosmopolitanism versus provincialism.
So, I guess, what we're witnessing now
is two tribes, basically, where there's
an enormous amount of miscommunication,
as you talked about with
regard to men and women.
But it's social, in a rather
stark and terrifying way.
- You're absolutely right.
And I'm gonna give a shout out now
to another book that was
just recently published.
It's called One Nation After Trump.
And it's by three very
gifted political scientists,
E.J. Dionne, Norm
Ornstein, and Thomas Mann,
who's right here in Berkeley.
And they are so convincing
and significant, I think,
in what they point out
how did we get here.
And they point out that Trump being...
I won't say being elected.
But becoming president is the culmination
of forces that can be traced very clearly
to Newt Gingrich in the Republican Party
and his decision that the way for
Republicans to gain power was to
oppose everything that the Democrats do
and to demonize government.
Make government into the enemy.
And to demonize journalists.
Make them the enemy.
And they show in this book
how this has been incremental,
but it didn't just come out of nowhere.
And so, you could say that
some of what they're describing there
is what I described in the
book The Argument Culture.
The valorization of attack
as a mean to an end.
- Let's look at the two candidates
in our last presidential election.
We were left with Trump for
various kinds of reasons
that defy conventional political wisdom.
But it's as if Trump now, as president,
is an extreme version of
a style of conversation
that emphasizes power,
hierarchy, and a dismissiveness
that's really quite extraordinary.
- Yes, well, for one thing,
it breaks all the norms
of political discourse.
Something, again, that
Ornstein, Dionne, and Mann
write about in their book.
It's normalizing a kind of discourse that,
in the past, you would have
seen only in the street.
It was not in the public domain.
So, sending out these
tweets, insulting people,
saying things that are completely untrue,
and, because you say them
and you say them again,
some people will believe you.
I think all of this is breaking
all the norms of political discourse
and that's partly what's
happening with Trump.
And this is, in a way, again,
it's the culmination of something that
we've been building toward for a while.
And that is what would have been
just in the conversational everyday domain
moving into the public domain.
So, whereas before...
And I've sometimes traced
this back to Ronald Reagan.
He was called a great communicator.
He was not a great orator.
But he was able to make
his public speeches sound conversational.
And that isn't a malign, in itself.
I mean, Clinton was great at that.
And I think he used it to good effect.
But I wanna say something I
think is so important here.
A lot of people are asking how
did Trump become president?
How did so many people vote for Trump
knowing what we knew about him?
I think it's equally important to ask
how did so many people not
vote for Hillary Clinton
given all the excellent
things we knew about her?
Given her vastly superior experience?
Her vastly superior fitness for office?
And I think there are two explanations.
And one is the argument culture.
From the time that she
entered the public stage,
way back, 1992, she was the wife of
a candidate in the Democratic primary.
I wrote an op-ed called
The Hillary Factor.
Whatever she did she was slammed.
Her hair in the beginning was very simple.
She kept it back with a headband.
She was ridiculed for that.
She had it styled and colored.
She's having a makeover.
She's manipulative.
She was thought to be childless,
which is quite stigmatized for women.
That was because they kept
their daughter, Chelsea,
out of the public eye.
So, they made it known
that they had a daughter.
She was accused, in Time Magazine,
for yuppie overdoting on her daughter.
I mean, these are kind of simple examples,
but whatever she did she was
slammed for and accused for.
And I think much of it was
a very knee jerk response
on the part of journalists
that they really felt it's their job
to always write negative things.
And this had...
So, there's a number of ways that
this played out in this last election.
One is we had been hearing
terrible accusations of her for decades.
And so, there's a smoke,
there's fire feeling to it.
She must have done something in Benghazi.
She must have done
something in Whitewater.
It turned out she didn't.
All those years of
Whitewater investigations
showed there was nothing.
No wrongdoing.
But the smoke is left.
And so, there's a feeling that
she's been criticized so much.
And, again, Ornstein and
the others make this point.
Trump had done so many things wrong that
every day there was a new scandal.
There was so little to
say against Hillary.
There was just emails,
which, by the way, again,
I believe was mostly fabricated.
A fabrication of how
serious this error was.
But you read about emails every day,
because they had to attack her, too.
And so, people ended up thinking
this email stuff was huge
and forgetting about all these things
that they read about him.
So, that's one thing I think
the argument culture...
All those years of attack.
And the other is what I write about as
a double bind that faces women
in positions of authority.
- And you wrote this in the 1990s.
- That's right, 1992.
- In a collection of
writers talk about Hillary.
- Yes, yes, yes, I have an
article called The Double Bind.
And it's in a book 13 Ways
of Looking at Hillary.
Yeah, so, just very briefly.
A double bind is a situation where
you have two requirements
you must fulfill.
But anything you do to fulfill one
actually violates the other.
When women are in positions of authority,
they have requirement be a good woman
and requirement be a good leader.
Our expectations of a good woman
and a good leader are at odds.
So, to be a good woman, you
should be self-deprecating.
You shouldn't seem too sure of yourself.
You shouldn't put yourself forward.
You shouldn't talk about
what you're good at.
If you're a good leader, you
should put yourself forward.
You should seem confident.
You should downplay anything you did wrong
and play up everything you've contributed.
And so, women are in a double bind.
If they fulfill our expectations
of a person in authority,
then they're respected,
but they're not liked.
If they fulfill our
expectations of a woman,
they're liked, but they're underestimated.
And I came upon this observation
and this way of looking at things
in research I did on
women in the workplace.
And that was a book called
Talking From Nine to Five.
That's where I first wrote about that.
Where women in positions of
authority in the workplace
faced this double bind and still do.
But it clearly was going on with Hillary.
And I believe that that played a huge role
in all the people who
would say things like
"I don't know.
I just don't like her.
Why is she shouting?"
She didn't talk any more
loudly than Bernie Sanders did,
but, when a man shouts,
he's addressing thousands of
people, you have to shout.
That felt okay.
But you hear a woman shouting,
it rubs you the wrong way.
- There's another element in this
that I wanna ask you about.
'Cause you have an interest in
communication on different platforms.
Trump was the first to
effectively use Twitter
in a political campaign.
What do you have to say,
as a linguist, about that.
Because it's really become
an important element of communicating.
He is in your face.
I'm the man.
I'm the boss.
Hierarchical way of thinking that
is so dismissive of anything that
tries to achieve solidarity,
asking people what they think, and so on.
- Well, there's a number of things
we could say about using
Twitter in this way.
First of all, it goes directly to people.
It cuts out all the middlemen in the past
that would have been a filter.
And sometimes that's good.
I mean, it's a little bit...
You could say an extension of
what Roosevelt did with fireside chats.
Go right to people.
Because of its brevity,
it becomes epithets.
You don't have to explain
what you're saying.
Just throw something out.
And he uses language that is completely...
Again, about breaking norms.
Completely inappropriate
to public discourse
and to diplomacy and to any sense of
the dignity of his office.
It's kind of like what you
would say in the street
when you're were mad at somebody
and you wanna cast aspersions on them.
But that is perfectly suited to Twitter.
And so, people that are his fans
pick this up and it's great.
They got their whole story.
They don't want the backstory.
They just get this little bit
and it resonates with them.
"He's insulting somebody.
I like that.
I insult people.
I think those people
are pretty crummy, too."
And so, it's satisfying, I think,
in a way that can be very
politically effective
in a very dangerous, of course, way.
- Does a linguist have anything to offer
about how we transcend
these tribal divisions?
It's cross-cultural communication now.
The world we're in.
What can we do about that?
- I'm asked this all the time.
And I so wish I had an answer.
I do believe that what we're dealing with
is way deeper than just
ways of using language.
Language is always a huge part of things.
I wish I could say if we talk this way,
we're gonna bridge those divides.
The problem is that there are
people who want these divides.
They're finding it useful.
And they are gonna continue to try to
stoke the flames of division.
And so, given that, what can we,
as the people who want
the divisions bridged,
what can we do?
I mean, if it's helpful to understand
what your enemies think,
yeah, you could listen.
You could try to get to the bottom
of what's motivating them.
I think that's always a good thing to do.
I think talking, personally,
to people who disagree with you
is always a hugely useful thing to do.
Both to understand what motivates them.
And, maybe, eventually, to try
changing their minds a bit.
And there, certainly, the
first thing to do is to listen.
Don't start right out trying to tell them
why they're wrong and you're right.
And maybe find some common ground
that you could build on to
offer another perspective
that they might consider.
But the broad forces
that we're up against...
The position that the
Republican Party has taken.
And they're one of the two
parties running our country.
That's very challenging.
And I'm not sure that I have
anything that I can recommend
in terms of language
that could work against that.
But I think trying to change
it in our personal lives
is certainly something worth doing.
When we feel ourselves
responding to others
in a really corrosive way...
"You're evil.
I'm good."
To maybe try to temper that
and reframe it in some way.
- After reading your
books and your papers,
I'm struck by, also,
it's possible relevance
to this free speech debate.
And I have a question for you,
which is, especially at Berkeley,
free speech meant something.
And we now have new actors who are
changing the conversation
about free speech,
because, really, their
metacommunication is not
"What I have to say is important."
But, rather, how can what I say disrupt
the context in which the
conversation is happening?
- This is becoming extremely complicated.
I think, at one time, that
Berkeley Free Speech Movement,
back in the '60s, was clear.
"The bad guys wanna suppress our speech.
We're the good guys.
We have a right to speak."
Now, that was pretty easy.
Maybe not easy to achieve,
but easy to feel clear on.
We now have people pointing out that,
if you allow people to speak
and what they're speaking is hate speech
and encouraging others to demonize
people who are different...
And it's true.
A lot of this is reminiscent
of times in the past
when speech that demonizes
people you disagree with
has led to violence.
And there's plenty of
evidence that it does.
You know, you're out there
saying you hate immigrants
and then someone goes and
beats up an immigrant.
Or shoots them.
So, it's very complicated.
Especially, I think, for people who
see themselves as liberal.
Who are inclined to be,
perhaps, free speech extremists.
Everybody should be allowed to speak.
I think there are people
who would see us liberals...
And I say us, because,
perhaps, at one time,
I would have been in that camp.
As part of the problem.
Because we are trying to make it easier
for people to speak in a way
that is going to incite violence
and lead to real, minimally,
discrimination and worse.
So, I think it's pretty...
It's become much more complicated an issue
than it seemed to be in the '60s.
- Professor Tannen, I want
to thank you very much
for joining us today.
It was a very informative conversation.
And I recommend that the audience go about
and buy, if not one,
several of your books.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you.
It's been a pleasure.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.